donald trump is worth two and a half
billion dollars which is a lot of money
but it's not enough money to make the
forbes 400. this year he falls 400
million dollars short and that's mostly
because he's lost 600 million dollars
since the beginning of the pandemic
pandemic has been great for technology
entrepreneurs so people in silicon
valley have added billions of dollars to
their fortunes as everybody goes online
while they're working from home
however for somebody like a new york
city real estate mogul the pandemic has
been a disaster people are not going
into office buildings tourists aren't
coming to new york city and nearly the
numbers they were before and shoppers
are staying away from places like fifth
avenue where donald trump owns
significant amounts of property
in 2016 after donald trump won the
election he faced a choice whether or
not to hold on to his business
most people thought that he was going to
sell trump even suggested that he was
going to get rid of all of his assets a
series of tweets that he issued in
november of 2016
but when the day finally came in january
of 2017 just before he took office
he said that he in fact was going to
hold on to his business this was against
what all the ethics experts had
suggested to him and in hindsight it was
a terrible business decision
the problem is that his business hasn't
performed very well at all over the last
four or five years so first the
presidency has damaged his brand
companies don't want to partner with
donald trump anymore because although
they might appeal to about 50 of the
american public they're not going to
appeal to the other 50
and no brand wants to take on that sort
of risk so that was a big problem for
him then of course we have the pandemic
which really damaged the value of hotels
of office buildings and also of retail
real estate
so in hindsight that move cost trump
billions of dollars if he had divested
at the start
and had sold off all of his holdings
even if he had paid the most possible
capital gains tax that he possibly could
have
and then took all of the proceeds and
put them in the s p 500 his fortune
today would be worth 4.7 billion dollars
that would be enough still for him to
make the 2.9 billion dollar cutoff of
the forbes 400 and it'd be a whole lot
more than his two and a half billion
dollar fortune that he currently holds
but he might not have even had to pay
those capital gains taxes because
there's a rule that when people join the
government
oftentimes they're encouraged to divest
and one of those encouragements
is that they say you don't have to pay
capital gains tax once you sell off a
bunch of stuff that's going to present
conflicts for you while you're in
government and if trump had been able to
secure one of those agreements which he
likely would have been able to do
then he wouldn't have started with a 1.1
billion dollar tax penalty at the
beginning instead he would have just
gotten to take his then three and a half
billion dollar fortune plow that for
example right into the s p 500 and if he
had done that then today he would be
worth seven billion dollars so he'd be
four and a half billion dollars richer
than he is today and he wouldn't have
had to worry about all the ethics
headaches and conflicts that he had to
deal with over the last five years
donald trump cares an inordinate amount
about his ranking and position on the
forbes 400. even before he got into
politics we said that there is no one no
one who cares as much about where he or
she ranks on that list
as donald trump so certainly the fact
that he's no longer on the list is
likely to bother him one indication that
we know
why he really really cares about
being on the list is because he lied in
the first place to get on it he said
that he held a significant amount of his
father's fortune
at a time when he did not
and the reporter who was putting
together the numbers at that time
later ended up digging up the tapes of
his conversation with someone who he
thought was an executive at the trump
organization but upon further listening
realized was donald trump himself posing
as one
john barron and claiming that he had all
sorts of assets that he did not in fact
have then during the presidential
campaign you know trump in the midst of
all of the craziness that was going on
took hours out of his day
in the fall of 2015 to sit down with
forbes and go through asset by asset
what he thought that all of his
companies were worth
every once in a while he would say a
number that was
accurate but most of them were not just
partially inflated or up 10 percent or
something like that but wildly inflated
so we know that this is someone who
cares an inordinate amount
about where forbes puts him on its list
and that it's a way that he measures
himself you know in the art of the deal
his famous book that he came out with in
the 1980s you know he said
i don't really care that much about
money which you know believe that if you
want but then he said but i do view it
as a way of keeping score
well by that score trump is getting
beaten right now not only by the overall
stock market but also by the rest of the
billionaires in the country
you